uh hey this is really funny donald
trump's lawyer i guess i don't know if
he's still his lawyer rudy giuliani
appeared yesterday morning on fox news
propaganda show fox and friends this was
ahead
of the first presidential debate and
rudy giuliani
blurted out this rambling conspiracy
about joe biden having dementia and as
he did it
the looks on the faces of the fox and
friends hosts
are they look like they're sick to their
stomachs it's kind of like a bizarre
stream of
consciousness take a look at this first
part from rudy giuliani
the man has dementia there's no doubt
about it
i've talked to doctors i've had them
look at 100 100 different tapes of his
five years ago and today the biden
people say he's fine
he can't recite the pledge of allegiance
and he's fine he's been a uh he's been
he was in the center for 160 years
i mean so this is already weird because
rudy says
biden can't recite the pledge of
allegiance it's trump
who has visibly struggled to recite the
pledge of allegiance
and the national anthem and
biden's been in the senate 160 years
rudy is making no sense whatsoever here
and okay the fox and friends crew is
starting to look a little bit concerned
but rudy's not slowing down he keeps it
going
he can't do the prologues or the to the
constitution
to the constitutional united states or
the declaration of independence any of
them
he can't do numbers wow are the numbers
screwed up
he actually displays symptoms that two
gerontologists told me are classic
symptoms of
middle level dementia it's so weird
because this has turned into the
projection
campaign everything that rudy giuliani
is expressing
is a supposed is everything rudy is
saying as a supposed concern
about biden is actually something that
we're worried about with trump
actual mental health and neurology
professionals
have been sounding the alarm about
donald trump for years
and rudy giuliani is trying to apply all
of those criticisms
to joe biden let's continue that's when
he does that i pledge allegiance
to the united states um uh uh i think uh
done that twice that's a that's a that's
a classic symptom
and the dsm-5 is the fifth symptom of
dementia he's got he's got he's got
eight of the ten
look that isn't the debate he'll he he
can get through it
i think the president is quite right to
say maybe he's taking adderall or
a uh some kind of attention deficit
disorder so
you know then with the adderall once
again it's donald trump who appears to
very clearly have upper
and downer days and it's donald trump
who the world
speculates is taking some kind of uppers
could be
adderall could be abusing allergy pills
according to michael cohen
could be abusing nasal decongestants etc
it's it's
do they not see this do they not realize
every allegation
that donald trump rather that rudy
giuliani is making about joe biden
has been applied seriously to donald
trump now it gets so bad
that fox and friends hosts try to
interfere a little bit they try to help
out rudy giuliani but rudy can't be
stopped he just keeps going
uh a uh some kind of attention deficit
disorder and that and that's why the
president wants to do a drug test but
you know none of us are done
this is just that's your opinion but so
it will be interesting to see what
happens tonight
it's not no it's not just my opinion
it's the opinion of a number of doctors
i've actually uh you know interviewed
right look let's talk about the supreme
court because that's going to be a topic
tonight at the debate
of course what are we and you hear brian
kilmeade there
saying we can stay away from this topic
and there is just
so much projection consider the
absurdity
of rudy giuliani rambling incoherently
through his claims that someone else has
cognitive issues
it's really incredible rudy mentions
10 dementia symptoms in the dsm-5
dsm-5 actually replaces the term
dementia
with major neurocognitive disorder
and mild neurocognitive disorder and it
doesn't list 10 symptoms i mean
everything rudy giuliani's saying here
is completely backwards
beyond the bigger picture that these
really are allegations that have been
credibly made
about trump which have not been answered
it's actually tragic in a way
i was never like a big rudy guy but
especially after 9 11.
rudy giuliani was truly he wasn't
universally loved
but in a polarized america after 9 11
rudy was
as close to universally loved as you
could imagine
and then be he became you know mayor 911
noun verb 911 became rudy giuliani's way
of speaking
he then jumped in with trump completely
and now he has sort of become it's
almost like he's the hatchet
kook who has to go around saying the
things trump would love to
be saying but finds himself stopping
short of
rudy giuliani is the guy out there doing
it just an irrelevant
crackpot making no sense whatsoever in a
way it's sad what's happened to rudy
giuliani
and meanwhile at a recent rally donald
trump said rudy should really run for
mayor of new york again
i have a hard time imagining rudy could
win at this point
tell me if you disagree we'll have more
coverage
of all of the shenanigans surrounding
the first presidential debate on the
show's
instagram page uh you can find it at
david pakman show on instagram
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is
helix sleep i sleep on a helix mattress
at home i absolutely love it and that's
why
i reached out to them about sponsoring
the david pakman show
buying a mattress in the past was always
a huge guessing game for me
i didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like
but helix has a sleep quiz on their
website you tell them your body type
your sleeping position
your back pain issues you might have and
their
tool matched me with a mattress that is
perfect
for me it's cool enough at night it's
the right firmness
i generally just do way better sleeping
these days because of the mattress helix
was awarded
number one best overall mattress for the
last two years
by both gq and wired magazine it is well
deserved i can tell you firsthand
every helix mattress comes with a 10
year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house
if you don't love it but i know you will
all of my viewers will get up to 200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video